bonjour eric verhaegue merci de répondre
en direct à nos questions sur arte
france selon certains médias donc
l'avenir des beurs philippe devrait se
jouer d'ici à dimanche
peut-être même avant pourquoi remanier
si les français selon le sondage que
l'on vient de voir à 57% souhaite voir
le premier ministre resté à son poste
car il ya quand même plusieurs raisons
qui justifient d'un remaniement en
profondeur c'est d'abord que beaucoup de
ministres de l'équipe actuelle sont en
difficulté on pense en particulier à
christophe castaner qui pose quand même
un sérieux problème au ministère de
l'intérieur et dont on voit bien que son
maintien en poste place beauvau va tôt
ou tard susciter des difficultés
incontrôlable pour le premier ministre
on a deux autres ministres qui sont
quand même en position compliquée on
sait que muriel pénicaud au ministère du
travail est quand même relativement
contester on sait que si bête ndiaye au
porte-parolat pose des problèmes
réguliers fait les choux gras de la
presse donc tout tout c'est où tous ces
ministres qui sont je parle même pas de
franck riester à la culture dont
personne n'entend jamais parler tous
ministre pose quand même de sérieux
problèmes donc il faut renouveler
l'équipe il faut la remanier et par
ailleurs emmanuel macron sens bien
qu'aujourd'hui il est débordé sur sa
gauche notamment par les écologistes et
que deux il ne peut donc pas rester dans
l'ancrage politique où il est depuis
2010 est plutôt marqué à droite alors
j'ai aussi besoin d'un changement de cap
vous parlais justement de la vague des
municipales la vague verte un profil
macron compatible à la fois libérale
sociale et écologiste
est ce que c'est beau possible on entend
beaucoup de noms incité dernièrement
mais aucun ne sont vraiment être
plébiscité par les français on entendu
bruno le maire gérald darmanin jean yves
le drian florence parly xavier bertrand
qui selon vous je me permets de revenir
sur votre question je suis pas sûr qu'il
ya une vague verte en france
en revanche les résultats aux
municipales ont montré que ceux qui ont
voté massivement macron en 2017 ont voté
largement pas massivement mais largement
écologistes en 2020 donc macro on est
obligé de suivre son électorat il cet
électorat prend soin de dire on n'est
pas vraiment pour une économie de gauche
en réalité on aimerait fermer les
centres villes aux banlieusards mais on
aimerait que ce soit plus écolo donc
cette personnalité là qui n'est pas
complètement sociale mais qui a une
fibre écolo et qui maintiendra ce que
j'appelle un ordre bourgeois une
réaction bourgeoise c'est à dire l'idée
que ben il ya les villes pour les
banlieusards où les ouvriers des villes
pour les les grands bourgeois des
centres villes des centres de métropole
c'est super cette personnalité là elle
est difficile à trouver ont évoqué le
nom de laurence tubiana qui a été madame
comme 21 qui est une proche de jospin et
qui a un peut piloter la convention
citoyenne
macron pourrait faire le choix de
piocher dans des personnes habilitées de
ce genre pour donner un nouvel axe est
une bouffée d'air correspondant à la
sensibilité de ces villes on a un peu
parlé de florence parly mais florence
parly n'est pas très marquée côté écolo
je crois assez qu'une personnalité comme
laurence tubiana pourrait en terme
d'image vis-à-vis de l'opinion changer
la donne
maintenant est ce qu'elle est capable de
faire de la politique comme les
politiciens en font c'est évidemment une
autre question beaucoup plus compliqué à
traiter je crois que la difficulté pour
macron lorsqu'ils voient l'épisode agnès
buzyn c'est de repas riez à nouveau sur
la société civile dans des fonctions
gouvernementales ou ministériel
puisqu'on voit bien que ça pose des
problèmes et que donc selon vous pas de
bruno le maire ou de gérald darmanin à
hama à matignon mais un remaniement
c'est ce choix là ce sera un choix qui
condamnera par avance toute
réorientation politique forte
si macro ont choisi bruno le maire ou
darmanin et probablement bruno le maire
entre les deux
ils actera le fait qu'il ne revient pas
sa politique massivement et qu'il ne
répond pas à cette poussée vers la
gauche qu'on a constaté aux municipales
justement dernière question rapidement
évidemment vous dites un remaniement
c'est pour changer de politique
est-ce qu'il va y avoir un changement de
cap selon vous et si oui est-ce que ça
en vue de la présidentielle de 2000 22
dans moins de deux ans donc je le
présente autrement je pense que macron
imagine un changement cap veut un
changement de cap annoncé un changement
de cap mais je ne suis pas sûr que sa
personnalité lui permettent de se
réinventer et il ya souvent loin entre
les désirs des manuels macron et ce
qu'il fait réellement
merci eric verhaegue d'avoir répondu à
nos questions en direct sur arte france
rappelle que vous êtes essayiste et
fondateur du blog politique
le courrier des stratèges